Edward Norton was deeply affected by the
experience of making American History X
partly due to the film's dark subject
matter and partly because the production
was a very troubled one here's why the
actor was never quite the same after
making this film in 1996 Norton's
performance in primal fear established
him as a formidable talent but it was
his starring role in 1998's American
History X that truly showcased his
talents in the film Norton plays Derek
Vinyard a neo-nazi who abandons his
ideology after spending some time in
prison he then tries to prevent his
younger brother Danny played by Edward
Furlong from following in his footsteps
as Norton told GQ in 2019 the film is
like even the poster was iconic it was a
Shakespearean type of a story by design
it's rare that an actor has to step in
and edit the film they're starring in
but that's exactly what Edward Norton
ended up doing that's because the making
of American History X proved to be
almost as controversial as the film
itself and the film was plenty
controversial in the middle of the
editing process director Tony K had some
serious creative differences with the
production company New Line Cinema K had
previously worked as an advertising
director and his experience in that
industry reportedly affected his editing
decisions in fact David McKenna the
film's screenwriter told The Telegraph
that Kay literally destroyed the movie
it was a commercial in the hopes of
salvaging the film Norton stepped in and
began working with K but they were
constantly at odds with one another
however many of Norton's edits did wind
up in the final cut of the film it was a
new experience for Norton but the skill
came in handy later he ended up Co
editing the 2005 Neel Western down in
the valley a film he also starred in
after filming wrapped on American
History X director Tony K was very
bitter towards Edward Norton and he
wasn't shy about letting the media know
his thoughts
The Telegraph quotes him saying that
Norton is a narcissistic dilettante
obsessed with his image obsessed with
screen time I was going to take
Hollywood by storm and I
would have but for that buffoon keep in
mind K doesn't seem particularly modest
himself I'm a storyteller so you know
making a television commercial is he's
telling a story of souls thanks to all
the drama behind the scenes during the
filming of American History X Norton
earned a reputation for being difficult
to work with but the actor rejects that
characterization as he told The
Telegraph difficult is really a question
of semantics you can use that word or
you can say rigorous committed you can
put it other ways and I'll tell you a
very true thing none of what I would
call the genuine talents I've worked
with directors have ever called me
difficult in a 2014 interview with Dan
Rather Edward Norton confessed that
making American History X was really
hard it was it was a gorilla kind of
experience
Norton put in some serious hours at the
gym to convincingly play Derek as men's
workout reports the actor gained 30
pounds of muscle in just three months
the magazine quotes Norton as saying I
knew this guy was going to have to be
really physically fearsome and defined
by rage arming himself against his own
emotional pain in this body he's created
is the physical manifestation of that
after the film was released people
suddenly perceived Norton as bigger
stronger and more intimidating as he
said on the Tim Ferriss show in 2016
doing that film created the strangest
distortion of perception on me he went
on to say it's unbelievable the degree
to which that film and the magic of
camera and art in black-and-white
photography and all these things made a
lot of people think that I was a larger
and tougher person than I am
it sounds like Edward Norton has never
been too concerned about box office
returns he'd much rather participate in
films that make a real cultural impact
to hear him say it American History X is
a film that really managed to capture
the zeitgeist and he's proud to have
been a part of it in 2010 he told / film
a lot of films are more successful
financially than Fight Club or American
History X but those films meant more to
people and continued to to me if I can
make a couple of films that looking back
people say yeah that's what our
generation felt like at that moment
that's a good document then I'm content
in a 2016 interview with ve T Norton was
asked whether he thinks the issue of
racism has changed since making the film
in 1998 he responded to a degree we're
not often comfortable acknowledging this
this current of racism sits under the
surface
he added that anxiety is often the cause
of those feelings saying people quote
have anxieties and they look for a
target Derrick goes through quite a
dramatic personal transformation in
American history X and that journey is
one of the things that really excited
Edward Norton about the character as he
told Charlie Rose in 1998 he goes on to
explain that it's not even so much just
the one very extreme manifestation of
this guy but more the emotional distance
that he travels but Norton had to do
more than convincingly portray Derrick's
hatred he also had to create a nuanced
character who could learn how to become
a more open-minded person throughout the
course of the film ultimately Norton
interpreted Derek Vinyard as a
classically tragic figure let's look at
someone who ruins all of the potential
in his life because of rage Norton also
wanted audiences to see something of
themselves in vineyard despite the
extreme and extremely ugly nature of his
character in 1999 he told the Guardian
an all-too-common reaction to something
like racism is to hate the act so much
you dismissed the person but in this
film you're forced to confront the
complexity of the character and his
tragedy check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]